펜트하우스는 500억이 좋기 될 것
드디어 우리나라도 이제 500억 정도
되는 주택이 나온다니 사실 여기에서
되게 놀랐던 포인트가
대피시설이 있습니다
[음악]
제가 오늘은 재미난
기사가 있어가지고 그 서초구에
방배역 인근에 있는 그 주택을 이제
신축하는 건데 저희가 이제 최근에
최고가는
워너 청담 펜트하우스가 이제
350억에
매각이 됐었는데 이거는 무려
서초에
500억짜리 펜트하우스가 생긴다라는
그런 기사를 제가
봤습니다
진짜
진짜 흥미로운 그런 주택인 것 같아서
오늘 좀 자세하게 설명드리겠습니다
일단은 건축 허가는 저번 주에 받았다
그러더라구요 그래서 아직 뭐 짓기
전이고 그래서 2025년에 건립할
예정이다 이렇게 뭐 기사로 나와 있고
트라우마우스가
2021년도에 전용면적 한 83평
정도가 185억에 팔린게 있어요
그래서 그걸 토대로 좀 이렇게
고급주택은 계속 좀 이렇게 최고가를
찍고 있다 뭐 이런 내용들이고
펜트하우스는 500억이 좋기 될
드디어 우리나라도 이제 500억 정도
되는 주택이 나온다니
뉴욕이나 이런 미국은 막 진짜
1000억짜리 넘는 주택들도
있었거든요 우리나라도 뭐
에테르노나 원어청담 뭐 ph129를
뛰어넘는 그런 주택이
곧 나올 것 같은데
에테르노 청담은 이게 되게 유명해진게
아이유씨가 이제 분양 받아 가지고
이슈가 됐던 거고 그래서 여기
펜트하우스도 한 300억 정도의
거래가 된 것을 알고 있습니다 그리고
그 옆에 원어청담도 펜트하우스가
350억 아마 기사 보셨겠지만 차가
이렇게 올라갑니다 거실까지 그래서
그걸로 좀 되게 이슈가 많이 됐던
그래서 지금이 주택도 보니까
각 세대의 내부 주차공간이 있고요 그
다음에 발레 서비스
입주자 차량 세차 서비스
입주자 전용 와인 나온지
스크린골프 휘트니스
센터 영화관 그 다음에 컨시어지 대기
서비스 기사 대기실
방문자 로비
홈서비스
요즘에는 이런 고급 주택이 다 이렇게
좀 호텔 서비스들이 좀 많이 있는 거
같아요 그래서 여기도 이제 다
적용이 돼 있고 사실 여기에서 되게
놀랐던
포인트가
대피시설이 있습니다
전 이거 보고
진짜 깜짝 놀랬어요 아 이제 이것까지
생각하는구나 그래서 여러분들 여기
보시면은
굉장히 잘 되어 있어요
약간 호텔처럼
핵 대피시설이 이렇게 돼 있습니다
그리고 여기가 아마
핵 대피시설 내에 이제 그 세대가
사는 그런 공간인 거 같아요 너무 잘
돼 있어요
지하 최하층의 핵 대피시설이 있고 그
다음에 3중 고강도
방풍문으로 되어 있고
쾌적한 실내 환경 유지시설 그래서
제가 또 기사를 보니까 그 방사능에도
좀 이렇게 막아줄 수 있고 그리고
전기가 끊길 경우도 다 대비해서 돼
있다고 합니다 그리고 만약에 이제
암반수도 돼 있기 때문에 뭐 물이나
이런 것도 충분히 가능하고 최소
3개월 이상은 뭐 버틸 수 있다고 뭐
그러네요 미학적
탁월함을 넘어 훗날에 이어질 첨단
기술의 집약체로서 마제스티엘은 어떤
순간 어떤 위협에도 그 자리를 오롯이
지켜가다 뭐 이렇게 문구가 있는데
약간 신기하네 이거 진짜
지워지면 너무 궁금한데 이거 가보고
싶네요
근데 사실 우리나라는 꼭
필요할 것 같거든요 지금 워낙
북한에서 위협을 많이 하고 있어서
만약에 이런 시설이 있다라고 하면은
위험을 느끼시는 자산가 분들은 되게
또 긍정적인
요소로 볼 수도 있을 것 같습니다
진짜 궁금해 가고 싶네
지하에 보통은 다
창고나 그런 거 수준만 있고
근데 그런 건 있어요 그러니까 예전에
이제 현대아파트 거기 가면 반공호막
이렇게 있거든요 비행물 쪽에 총 쏠
이렇게 그 호를 만들어 놨어요
현대아파트네
지하도 이렇게 돼 있고 바로 문제
생기면
지하로 내려가서 최소 3개월 이상은
내가 버틸 수 있으니까 뭐 전쟁이
나든 뭐 해그리스도 뭘 하든 여기
숨어 있으면 되니까 나중에 만약에
지어진다고 하면은 꼭 가서 보고
싶네요 그래서 아마 1층은 이렇게
모비나 라운지 공간으로 하고 2층부터
이렇게 13층까지 있는 거 같아요
그리고 여기 위치가 여기거든요 여기
이제 방배역 여기 2번 출구에서
거리가 그렇게 멀진 않아요 여기 이제
방배 근린공원 바로 앞에 있거든요
산 좋아하시는 분 그러니까 이제 되게
조용하고
뭔가 프라이빗한
곳 좋아하시는 뭔가 자산가 분들은
괜찮으실 것 같습니다 제가 말씀드린
고급주택은 다 청담 뭐 한남동
한남더힐이나 라인원
성수 뭐 그런데 있는데
서초는 좀이 정도 규모는 또 이번이
처음이거든요
과연 이렇게 지어질지가 일단 궁금하고
분양은 어떻게 될 건지 그게 가장
궁금한 거 같습니다 여기가 이제
펜트하우스 같아요
그림상으로 봐도
진짜 말도 안 되는
럭셔리한 공간 같습니다
뭐 제가 기사 보다가 좀 되게
흥미로운 주제 같아서 오늘 찍어봤는데
이거 나중에 좀 어떻게 지워질지
여러분들 좀 관심있게 보시면 좋을 것
같아요 우리나라의 최초의 최고가
500억짜리 펜트하우스가
지어지는 거고 그리고 좀 다른
곳과 다르게
핵 데뷔 시설이 있다 그런 것도
자산가분들이 좀 이런 핵 대피시설까지
좀 고려를 할까 이런 걸 좀
생각해보면 좋을 것 같습니다